Carson Palmer of the Arizona Cardinals
here on the Rich Eisen show how you ben
Carson rich I'm doing great how are you
I'm doing better for you calling in what
do you think first plus you're the news
out of the NFL League meeting that
overtime is now going to be five fewer
minutes what do you think of that idea I
like it I didn't know that that's that's
the first I've heard of it
okay I'm breaking news I like it it
makes sense I've been in some long
overtime games and and it's a long
season there's a lot of plays in each
game if you can shorten those up and get
a win out of it
without having to play so many plays get
you ready to play next week and recover
it I like it I'm a fan of it well the
idea of it is is that yes it is born out
of player safety and just hearing what a
lot of fans are thinking about it even
Josh Norman of the Redskins said
yesterday that it appears to be a drop
in the bucket though when it comes to
keeping players fresh you you would say
opposite first blows but let's play the
less plays you play the fresher you are
you know the less the less plays you
play the less opportunities you have to
get an injury the quicker the quicker
your body recovers for the next week so
you know I'm sure these young 22 23 year
old guys that come League could care
less but being a more experienced player
in this league with more years I like
trying to stay as fresh as possible and
limit or limit as you know as much as
you can the injury possibilities and get
ready to recover for your next game well
I like how you use the word experienced
not old cars old not old I like that
very word know you're more experienced
and in that regard you know I read an
interesting piece in The New York Times
about what your offseason throwing
program looks like this year with you
and coach Aaron's you're going to throw
less this year to keep pressure that
driven throwing less yeah yeah I've been
throwing less really haven't thrown more
than a you know two or three hundred
balls so far normally it's in the
thousands by now by May
so yeah I've cut back on a ton of throws
just trying to just trying to save the
the good ones I have left and hold on to
as many of them as I can not waste them
in April and May so what would be the
theory behind having as many throws as
you used to have why would that be
helpful
or at least that it that would be more
than norm for a lot of players around
the NFL a lot of quarterbacks around the
NFL yeah I was just you know first 14
years of my career it was just a
repetition hog and and I wanted to get
every rep I wanted to get every throw
and you know at some point you know you
only get so many throws in your arm you
know you only get so many golf swings
you only get so many Sprint's whatever
sport it may be so being a thrower I've
thrown you know probably close to you
know hundreds of thousands of balls and
you know it's more mental right now and
I still work my arm out in every
possible way without throwing you know
all the all the shoulder stabilization
all the you know the the quickness the
speed and and all the things you do to
upkeep your arm and offseason
I've just cut out you know a majority of
the throws up until this point and in
terms of the other piece of news that
might be coming out of the owners
meeting is a relaxing of the celebration
rules that they're going down to the
ground and returning the rules to
allowing the use of the ball as a prop
what are your thoughts on that Carson
Palmer I like it yeah I like it just
because I'm so tired everybody
complaining about it so hopefully now
guys will stop complaining about it and
and the celebration part of the game is
fun you know that's especially these
young guys coming in that that's part of
the the excitement of getting the NFL is
you know except for last year the years
prior guys were excited to be able to
spike a football and dance and do all
these fun things that they've been held
back from doing for so long because you
know there was there was such a negative
you know thought about about a player
that celebrates and players in the NFL
been dancing and spiking the football
and Dunkin footballs and you know all
that kind of stuff for so long that guys
got excited about getting here then all
of a sudden disappeared so now it's back
I'm excited we don't have a ton of guys
that are that our big celebration guys
but it brings some excitement to the
game I think the fans like it and that's
what's important so are you saying that
should you get in the endzone you will
not have a carson palmer celebration
already teed up so well
if I was just my just my I've been known
to cut a rug
and I don't look like it but I have a
little bit of the rhythm and now that
I'm allowed to dancing and I might have
something okay let's try and cook
something along a phone well that could
be the name of the dance
hold the phone yeah yeah I like it you
know what else you why don't you take a
video and text message it to me so I can
watch it in practice and I'll get it
ready for the opener about okay so now
that would have you by the way are you
aware of how many touchdowns career
touchdowns you have own like oh no but
everybody well let's get just give me a
gimme gimme um just give me a Carson
Palmer stab at the number of career - uh
it's a single-digit it's got to be
single-digit okay you're getting one you
Cal Pop Warner and high school no I'm
just um well I mean no just nothing I'm
just looking at your pro football okay
numbers okay yeah I'm going to say if
the over-under was a tie would take the
under or you'd push would nailed it you
nailed it on that it's eight I actually
have a stat guy here just like you do
how old is your stat guy does your stat
guy wearing diapers or what how Elvia
mark Dalton is 47 Oh mark Dalton one of
the best PR men in the national TV and
one of the bulk a bet pardon me pardon
me Carson Palmer joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show so uh you know in all
seriousness though the conversation
that's been had born out of Tom Brady's
wife going on the CBS Morning Show and
saying that Tom had a concussion last
year and it wasn't diagnosed you did you
were in the concussion protocol would
you ever remove yourself from a game if
you had something that seemed like it
and and nobody buzzed down nobody
noticed it but you noticed it would you
take yourself out Carson I think so I've
been very fortunate I've had one real
one one one one major one and that was
last last offseason and I didn't know
which way was up in which way was down
so there really was an opportunity for
me to go back in the game and
and our our from Tom Murray to everybody
on our sideline there also on top of it
each game I mean I I get sick of it
during games sometimes you know some guy
come up by me say all right here I guess
how you get hit and they're just doing
their job and you have to accept that
but our guys are so on top of it that I
don't think I would have that
opportunity to put myself back in the
game because they do such a good job of
noticing it and staying on top of it but
I've been fortunate like I said to not
have you know very many instances where
I would put myself back in or think
about you know am i okay do I have a
concussion the one I've had I it was the
game was over it was night for me so you
know I can't really put myself in those
shoes just because I feel like we're so
on top of it and and we're so we're so
protected and and there's so many
doctors now in so many neurologists and
experts and all these people that stay
on top of it and handle that for us well
when you came off the campus at USC -
now how has it changed the conversation
amongst players about concussions
they're more conversations about it is
there because because the reason why I
asked again is that this whole issue
with Brady is being brought up is that
players still would not report whether
they have a concussion or not and that
there's a concern about it and that that
even though there's more information it
still hasn't if you will figuratively
sunk in Carson yeah I mean I think it's
different for for every player and every
teen maybe I don't feel like in my my
tenure in the league I feel like there's
more discussion or less discussion about
it within players within the locker room
there's definitely tremendously more
discussion outside doing interviews when
it's you know when when the media is in
our locker room and and as you said that
the different topics that have come up
recently but as far as players concerned
I you talk about it and it's part of the
game and it's been part of the game for
all of us for as long as we've worn a
helmet and played football but I don't
think the discussions have picked up in
any way there's always going to be guys
that you know they might have a fracture
and a bone and their wrist
or they might have sprained an MCL and
obviously those aren't dealing with your
head but this game is played with
injuries and pains and aches and
unfortunately sometimes with concussions
that guys may know about may not know
about sometimes you just you're just not
sure you're so focused on what's going
on but I just don't think I don't feel
like I hear more discussion within our
locker room between actual players
anymore than I did 10 15 years ago well
how about you with your wife and your
family as your as your now more
experienced to use your phrase in your
career when your might be on a
year-to-year plan are you talking about
it more personal my wife talks about all
the time you know she unfortunately
witnessed she was down in the locker
room with me and and I just was
completely out of it
when I was going through all the
protocol and meet with the doctors after
the game I had it in and that's it's
just scary you know I don't as a player
and when it happens you don't remember
for them for the most part you have no
idea I don't recall from 2:30 on that
afternoon but your family members and
your wife and your kids experienced it
and they're right there and it's scary
you know it's it's um but it's
especially for young kids that haven't
seen something like that it's scary and
it's something that our wives and our
moms and our families and people around
us on the outside I'm sure worry a lot
more than we actually do as players it
lasts a couple minutes left with Carson
Palmer here Larry Fitzgerald saying he's
going to one time talk about his future
in training camp can you perhaps give a
little hint to the show listeners and
viewers what do you might want strany
camp it's of course I'm hanging on I'm
hanging on the edge of my seat just like
you are rich I really I don't know I'm
not asking I'm not bugging them about it
it's I think that answer came from being
bugged about that question over and over
and over again but no I'm I don't have
any hints I'm not sure I'm just happy
he's back this year all right how's
David Johnson doing how's he doing he's
awesome he's awesome me he might have an
even better year this year in every way
I mean he's such a special player and a
special individual and
everything you could ask for in a
teammate and really excited for him me I
think he like I said it's going to be
tough to eclipse what he did last year
if anybody can do it on this planet it's
him yeah I mean that's pretty scary so
basically what you're saying to me is
draft him first in my fantasy league if
I get it opportunity and you don't know
about Larry and you will perform they
hold the phone
celebration dance with now props being
allowed in the NFL
again you will do that for this shows
listenership and viewership Carson
pompous okay and it and it's going to be
really good you just you have to add
that really good 10 out of 10 you're
going to get the gold ticket out of that
thumbs up okay
Carson take care man good chat rich good
the [ __ ] you man thanks for having me
always
that's Carson Palmer the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience if you like that video be
sure to download our app and I'll be
sure to move week six games to Saturday
for that wedding you have to go to